Five four,
three,
two,
one,
boom.
And we're off.
What's up brother?
How are Ya?
Good,
good.
Thanks for having me on my pleasure.
Nice to meet you,
man.
You know,
it's,
it's funny that you just brought up
doctor a Tia.
You know,
when we were,
we were,
you were saying that you download the
podcast.
You were saying,
I got to get that guy on.
Yeah,
yeah.
It was funny.
I was auto downloads and that one popped
up and I remember thinking about a week
before that I was like,
well,
when I,
when we first scheduled this one,
I was like,
I told Joel about Doctor [inaudible].
He was one of the kind of first guys I
really followed when I kind of dove in
10 of the high fat approach to
nutrition.
So,
um,
yeah,
he's a fascinating guy who was a great,
listen,
I had to listen to it like twice.
Yeah.
He's a weird guy.
He's one of those guys.
We talked to them and you think,
oh,
this is a good,
normal,
really nice guy.
And then as he starts getting into the
medical aspect of things,
you go,
oh,
okay.
You're a fucking super genius.
Yeah.
He's tricks you.
I remember one of the first things he
ever said that really kind of resonated
with me was I think someone was asking
him about like,
what the facts are or where the key to
genic die in terms of like micro
nutrients and what maybe he'd be missing
based on kind of like that normal
profile of what you're supposed to get.
And he was just like,
you know,
it's,
it's interesting because most of those
studies in recommendations are based off
of basically a standard American diet or
higher carb Diet.
So he's like,
well,
you might not need the same,
we need to do more.
And he's always looking to kind of push
the envelope a bit.
So cool guests for sure.
Yeah.
And you know,
I'm fascinated by you and I'm fascinated
by anybody who does the kind of shit
that you do.
I mean,
please explain to people all the
different ultra marathons you've done
and what you've accomplished.
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's interesting because like,
I still kind of see myself as a pretty
average runner because like,
um,
I mean I competed in high school and
made state cross country and state track
and that kind of thing,
um,
for a small school.
And then I went to a small division
three school and was,
you know,
pretty much,
average amongst a real good program at
the d three level.
And,
uh,
I always just did kind of like running
longer though.
So,
um,
like once I got done with college,
I kind of decided,
well,
let's,
let's see what's longer than that.
Some of those traditional like
collegiate races have like five k to 10
kilometers and a,
and I started kind of just dabbling that
stuff.
And then in 2010,
I think I actually did my first ultra
marathon,
you know,
partly because I was just like looking
around and there turned out to be one in
the state.
I was,
I was living in Wisconsin at the time
and,
uh,
there was one that,
was kind of in my neck of the woods and
I actually had just decided to go back
to Grad school and that one had a
thousand dollar prize purse on it.
And I was like,
you know what,
if I,
if I can win that thousand bucks,
go a long way during Grad school.
So I did that one and I ended up winning
it and it,
uh,
it definitely hooked me.
It was like the type of thing where I
was like,
I want to do more of these.
And,
um,
by 2011,
I kind of jumped all lane at the end of
the year and ended at three 50.
And I think it was about a nine week
timeframe.
And,
uh,
it's so crazy.
Yeah.
And I mean,
it gets crazier.
There's,
there's some freaks out there.
There's guys who will do like a couple
and the weekend and stuff like that.
So,
I mean,
it's,
it never ends.
Um,
but yeah,
you know,
it was one of those things where after
that I was totally hooked.
So what is it that got you hooked?
Um,
you know,
it had to be partly just a little bit of
success.
You know,
I wasn't necessarily used to winning.
So like,
I mean I've had good races and good
times relative to what you probably see
like in an average person.
But you know,
when I went to like a competitive 5k
competitive marathon or something like
that,
um,
you know,
I wasn't going to win unless it was kind
of a local race.
So kind of finding,
you know,
it's like anything,
I guess you kind of gravitate to what
you feel you're good at and then that
kind of Piques your interest.
Um,
so that was part of it.
The other part was just I really enjoyed
doing the long run.
Like when you break up kind of like a
training week,
you can have like a variety of different
things.
You've got like kind of,
you know,
base level runs,
you've got specific workouts for the
distance and then most training programs
are going to have a long run once a
week.
And that was the one that was always my
favorite.
So wrapping my head around doing a bunch
of those a week instead of just one was,
was really it kind of appealing to me.
And when you're putting that much time
into whatever you're training for,
it's,
I think important to enjoy it.
So being able to kind of enjoy the
training process a lot was really
appealing to me.
Um,
and uh,
and then it's just the variables when
you're out there for that long,
there's so many variables to consider
and it's like,
it's a blast for me to kind of like work
through those,
plan for those and then adjusted them on
the fly when you're out there and,
you know,
things inevitably go wrong or things pop
up that you didn't expect.
So it's,
it's,
uh,
it's just,
it's,
it's kind of hard to explain,
but it's,
it's weird.
One of the things in ultra marathon
running that people will always say is
like,
they'll have a race and even if they
have a bad race,
say like,
I'm never doing one of these again.
And then the next day they're on,
uh,
on the Internet looking for another
race.
So it's this weird thing about it that
you don't really know until you do it,
but it,
it sucks you in.
That's the case with a lot of people
only talk about things that are like,
they have to suffer through.
You know,
I've heard that when guys talk about
like those extreme hikes,
you know,
when they,
like they do that,
you know,
that one that goes from Georgia all the
way to Maine,
you know that it's insane.
Like what does that call the Appalachian
trail?
Yep.
Yeah.
Did they say,
I've never fucking do that again.
And then they're like,
okay,
what other,
what other hikes can I go?
It's just once the pain,
the physical pain dies down.
There's something about that challenge
that stimulates in people like you and
people that are into these really long
distance things.
Like there's something about distance,
there's something about like,
like you were saying like you weren't
the best runner in high school or
college,
right?
But there's something about the mind of
an ultra marathoner.
It's a different mind.
The purse,
the type of person that can run a
hundred miles,
200 miles,
238 miles,
those type of people,
they're different people.
And there's like,
there's a strength,
a mental strength in the ability
to just keep going on and on and on.
That I'm absolutely fascinated with.
Yeah.
You know,
it is interesting too,
because it's a,
in the sport's grown a bit,
quite a bit in the last decade or so,
but it's still very much kind of a niche
group.
And then when you kind of hang out in
that group,
you start to kind of normalize it a
little bit,
I think.
So then you start thinking like,
oh,
a hundred miles,
it's just what we do.
And then you,
you know,
he actually tried to like separate
yourself from the fact that you've done
a few of those are separate yourself
from the fact that you've been hanging
out with other people who are doing it
and you realize,
oh,
this is actually kind of a weird thing
to kind of do as,
as a human nowadays.
It's very weird.
How many of these things of you?
One,
uh,
I don't know how many I've won it.
It's,
I think I've done just shy of 50 total
now.
Um,
you know,
everything from 50 kilometers to the
furthest I've done is 200 kilometers,
which is about 125 miles.
Um,
yeah,
I,
I'd have to look to see how many I've
won.
It's,
it's,
it's really goofy cause when you start
getting into the longer stuff,
like a hundred miles and beyond,
you start,
at least in my training program,
you start to kind of pick smaller races
to kind of use as training runs.
Um,
and some of it I think is just because
for me,
if I'm going to go out and do like a 30
mile or 40 mile training run or
something like that,
it's kind of tedious to do that by
herself and then plan all the logistics
of it.
So if there's a race nearby and that's
not too hard to get to,
it's easy just to sign up for that,
go and do that.
So some of those,
you know,
I'll,
I'll win if they're,
if they're small enough,
even though I'm not necessarily trying
to go forward,
you know,
go all out so to speak,
cause I'm hoping to recover kind of and,
and get back into training.
Um,
you'll pace yourself at one of these
local races maybe.
Yeah.
You know,
the way I described it is,
um,
and this is,
this is a real hard thing for a lot of
people to do.
I think it's a,
like you go into a race saying this is
going to be a moderately difficult long
run.
Uh,
so maybe a little faster than what I
would do if I was just going to do it by
myself,
like on supported,
that sort of thing.
And then I always tell myself 80% is the
hardest you can go if you want to be
able to come back and start training on
time to meet the actual goal or the
race.
Um,
so when I do those,
it's like,
it's one of those things where like,
you know,
who knows,
someone might show up that's,
that's like as fast as you or maybe a
little slower than your normal.
And if they're deciding to just hammer
it that day,
they might beat you and you gotta be
okay with that.
Um,
the competitive part of you flare up
though?
Well,
yeah,
it does.
And that's the hardest part.
And that's,
I think the main reason why some people
won't do that approach because there are
certainly people who just,
they stay away from races and less,
it's there a race and they just say,
I'm,
if I'm going to do a long run,
I'll do it on my own and,
and,
you know,
not do that.
Or,
you know,
there's certainly,
I'm sure folks who do it and then they'd
get caught up and then ended up leaving
there a race out on,
on the b race,
I guess,
so to speak.
So,
um,
yeah,
it's interesting.
It's,
uh,
it's kind of a,
a sport that I think is still a lot to
learn,
which I think is actually the case for a
lot of things that,
you know,
even things that are well established,
there's always something to learn
or new things to pick up on.
Well,
it's one of those things,
right when we went,
once someone runs a hundred miles and
then a bunch of other people start doing
it,
like you said,
it almost becomes normalized and then
people start to try to push that
boundary.
Now I've been hearing,
talk about the woman candace who runs
the Moab to 40.
Yeah,
yeah.
They're talking about doing a 500 I
heard that.
I was like,
here,
you're out of your fucking mind.
People are going to die,
but maybe that'd be normal in five years
and we'll get used to like four or five
day races.
Yes.
So it's really fascinating.
It took me a couple of years to do this
before I got into the sport,
but once I was in it for a couple of
years,
I kind of did a little,
a little,
a little research to see like what the
deal was with them.
Some of this stuff.
And the,
the funny thing is that type of a
distance isn't even unheard of.
They actually,
I forget what the book is called,
but they actually had in Madison Square
Garden,
they used to host a six day event where
guys and Gals,
I'm not sure if gals were doing it back
then,
but um,
guys for sure we're going there and
seeing how far they could run in six
days.
And uh,
yeah,
I know crazy.
And uh,
I think if I remember right,
they would actually,
people were betting on them that way and
so they'd fill it up.
Like people would come and watch us like
spectacle.
It was in the late 18 hundreds I think
is when they started it.
I'm not sure.
Oh,
here it is.
Six Day cycling,
the six day grind at Madison Square
Garden Valley ranch.
Oh Wow.
Look at this map to some crazy person
decided to leave the bike at home.
I guess this is super old.
We're looking at this on youtube folks.
It says six day cycling,
the six day grind at Madison Square
Garden,
and so it's just a track and these
people are,
this is old timey shit.
This looks like the 30s right.
That guy just went down and so they're,
they're just riding their bike for six
days.
Oh Shit.
When they wipe out.
Oh my God,
they probably a terrible breaks back
then,
right?
Yeah.
That was their feet probably right,
or the railing.
Yeah.
So this is so endurance sports like this
or nothing new.
Yeah.
It's actually fascinating when you like
kind of look into it because nowadays in
the United States,
the trail running scene is definitely
way bigger than like the road running or
certainly the track,
the track scene,
but that wasn't always the case.
If you look back and be like the 70s and
eighties there was a pretty big surge
and ultra marathon running a for flat
bass stuff.
That's where we see a lot of the,
the records coming from.
Um,
so that's like a track and you run as
far and long as you can on a track like
track or a road or really flat road.
I had goggins on David Gardner.
Yeah.
And he was talking about the first time
he did one was on a track.
Okay.
Ran In circles on a track,
which is almost got to be more taxing
for your mind cause you're just seeing
the same shit over and over and over
again.
Yeah.
It's really fascinating because I've
done,
I've done both.
I've done a hundred miles on the trail
and I've done a hundred miles on a 400
meter track.
And uh,
the fascinating thing is it is like what
you said,
it's almost a different event where
mentally you're doing everything you can
on that track to kind of separate
yourself from the actual
environment and envision yourself being
somewhere else.
You know,
looking forward a little things to kind
of not necessarily be thinking too far
and advanced cause that can get
overwhelming.
Whereas when I'm out on the trails,
it's like you're using a pretty
pristine,
beautiful area and you can kind of just
take it as it comes and say,
Oh cool,
now I get to see that,
or this is a neat area,
or I like this section.
And you look,
you look forward to that kind of
diversity.
Whereas on the track it's,
you know,
you see it once and you've seen it every
time.
Um,
and then it,
you know,
it just kind of beats you up mentally
from that side of things.
Um,
but then,
you know,
there's other things about that too
that,
that help out.
Like logistically,
when you're on a track for foreigner
meters,
you bring out one person,
you put everything you might possibly
want on a little table.
And if I want something,
I say,
Hey,
can I get that 400 numbers later?
I have it.
And even,
even if we mess it up,
I'll get it 400 years after that.
So yeah,
we're,
whereas,
you know,
the trails,
it depends.
They've gotten a lot better with aid
stations as the sport's grown.
Um,
but like,
you know,
you mess up your aid station or if you
get caught up in the moment and just
blow through it and don't take care of
yourself,
you might have to suffer for an hour
plus before you get help again.
So that's where it kind of gets a little
different I think logistically when
you're on the trails versus versus on
the road.
And um,
but,
but yeah,
it's,
it's kind of a different thing.
The track is interesting too in the
sense that you're essentially making
that same exact motion,
exact motion,
the whole way.
So like there's certain areas of your
body that fatigue,
um,
and they don't get a break on the turn
and just running flat,
like running flat.
You're going to kind of localize some of
the way you stimulate your muscles or
your gate is going to be pretty similar
throughout.
Whereas when you're on the trails,
like you might be going on a slight
incline,
a steep incline,
slight decline,
a little bit of flat,
some rolling and all kinds of things in
between.
And then trails can be kind of
undulating.
So you're just kind of moving all that
force is around your legs a little more
than you would be when you're running on
a flat surface.
So,
you know,
it's one of the things that I always
tell like my coaching clients and,
and myself when I'm planning for
something,
it's like if you really want to meet
your full potential,
like specificity is king.
You need to be on that environment in
the environment you're going to race on
and really get your body used to kind of
that type of a motion.
And um,
it makes it a little more interesting
when you're doing a track race cause
that means some kind of long runs on a
track.
So,
um,
you're kind of balancing doing just
enough to get ready for it and not doing
too much so that when you get to the
race you're like,
screw this.
I've done too much of this already.
I don't want to see another loop.
Um,
that's kind of a,
an interesting concept.
It's,
it's interesting to me too that you're,
if you're planning to run a hundred
miles,
like what you were saying about running
these shorter races as a training run,
which makes sense because how else are
you going to prepare for a hundred
miles?
Like if he just decided to just go out
and run a hundred miles,
you'd have to like map it out.
Like how far is a hundred miles?
Where am I going to park?
Where am I going to put water?
And Yeah.
And then people will also kind of get
like,
forget about the aspect of just all the
stuff surrounding the race that you can
kind of fine tune when you're doing a
race as a kind of training run where
like,
you know,
usually you're going to travel a little
bit for stuff like,
um,
so you're probably going to stay in a
hotel the night before you're going to,
you have to wake up early in the morning
and have to get yours,
your,
your gear ready.
And so it's Kinda like going through
that process of what you're gonna have
to do on race day.
So then when you're big race comes up,
you're like,
okay,
I've done this three or four times in
the last six months,
so I know what I'm doing
now.
What's different between you and a lot
of guys,
and this is one of the reasons why I
wanted to talk to you about this,
is that you,
you are on a fat burning diet.
You're essentially,
you're on a ketogenic diet and running
these races.
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's a little interesting because the
way I kind of the,
at least the way I came into it,
like I explored the ketogenic diet
mainly because I started noticing some
things.
Oh,
sorry.
No worries.
Yeah.
So I started kind of exploring the
ketogenic diet back in late 2011 because
I started noticing some,
some goofy things going on with my body
from,
from the,
from the high level of training and
then,
and then the racing.
And um,
that was right around that same time I
did those three 50 milers and nine
notice.
Uh,
I would wake up like three or four times
at night and then like,
I'd have to like pee all the time at
night and I'd have like swelling in my
ankles and stuff a lot.
I'll just like huge energy swings
throughout the day.
Like I would,
you know,
I was,
I was a teacher at the time,
so I remember thinking like every day at
like one or two o'clock,
I could have laid down and take a nap on
spot if I had had the opportunity to.
So it was just like a lot of weird
things that I thought was pretty
abnormal for 25 year old male at the
time.
Um,
and so it was kind of becoming clear to
me that what I was doing was either
unsustainable or the way I was doing it
was unsustainable.
And you know,
I was really intrigued by the sport and
I didn't really want to necessarily back
off of that if I didn't have to.
So that's when I kind of started to
explore nutrition and diet and things
like that.
And,
um,
I was very much following what I would
have considered a healthy diet before
that.
At the time it was,
it was high carbohydrate,
but it was like what you would think of
as a healthy high carbohydrate diet with
like what was a normal meal.
Um,
you know,
I wake up and I usually go for a run and
then have like some oatmeal,
raisins,
maybe some fruit or something like that,
some,
some eggs or something with,
with that in the morning.
So not junk food,
just know it was clean.
It was like clean,
like,
you know,
you know what you say,
they say like get your whole grains,
fruits,
vegetables,
that sort of thing.
I definitely,
you know,
focused heavily on that and made sure I
wasn't eating like junk,
junk food.
I wasn't going through fast food
restaurants or eating oreos and bond
bonds and that sort of thing.
So,
um,
so it was kinda interesting to me to
think like,
okay,
I didn't really realize that it was
necessarily the nutritional side of
things.
Like,
it wasn't,
it wasn't like a big slap in the face
and the sense that,
oh,
I just got to cut out the junk.
Cause like according to most people,
I wasn't eating junk.
I was eating really good food.
Um,
so,
you know,
that's when I Kinda got introduced to
some folks,
like a doctor Valek and doctor Finney
who were kind of,
I guess,
I guess the pioneers of like the,
this latest way of,
of kind of the high fat approach.
And,
um,
you know,
they were,
I started reading their books,
listening to podcasts and things like
that.
And,
and it,
you know,
it was interesting because I was,
I was training upwards of 20 hours a
week at the time.
And you know,
I started kind of thinking like,
uh,
how much time am I going to invest in,
in just running,
you know,
how can I kind of kill two birds with
one stone?
And,
and that's kind of when I discovered
podcasts and thought,
this is sweet.
I can learn something and train at the
same time.
Um,
and so I just kind of like,
went all in on listening to a bunch of
podcasts and stuff like that.
And I'm actually one of your previous
guests.
Uh,
Ben Greenfield was one of the first
podcasts I really kind of did a deep
dive into and he was always kind of like
a ruling out stuff that was like kind of
new or cutting edge.
So like,
um,
he definitely had a lot of information
there.
And,
uh,
I was facing mania,
don't take his advice on what he does
with his dick shooting stem.
So when it was dick,
he's turning himself into a Guinea pig,
but he's an odd duck.
But yeah,
he definitely had a lot of info from
guys like Doctor Finian,
Doctor Walik and uh,
and I was lucky to meet those guys too
on a couple occasions.
And,
um,
with,
with doctor Valek,
I've done some podcasts with him and
certainly in like exchange emails and
stuff when I've had questions.
And,
uh,
so I kind of just tested it out,
you know,
I was like,
what's the worst that can happen?
I can just,
I can always go back.
You know,
like it's not like I have to stick to
this to for the rest of my life if it's
not something your issues were swelling
and energy and why did you attribute
that to your diet?
Like what was making you think that as
you'd died and that was doing that too.
Yeah.
So you know,
I wasn't sure.
I thought,
I thought for sure that something I was
doing was wrong and get your blood work
done,
check your hormone levels,
all that stuff.
Yeah.
You know,
I didn't have probably as much blood
work done as I would've liked you to
really be like look at stuff and see
like the way I look at blood work is if
you're doing it regularly,
like often enough and not changing
things,
that's what you're going to see the
most.
Cause you're going to see changes versus
just like,
oh,
I'm chronically low in this or I'm
always low in this,
but it doesn't seem to be an issue.
Uh,
but you know,
there was no big red flags on my blood
work.
Like nothing that would have said said
like thyroid disease,
right.
Nothing,
nothing quite that wrong.
And you know,
it wasn't like the wheels were coming
off at that point.
There were,
these were small things that I kind of
associated like nagging things.
They,
they were like things I could get
through.
Um,
but they weren't ideal.
So,
you know,
I'm,
I've kind of been a curious person like
my whole life.
So I was,
um,
it was just looking to kind of optimize
I guess more or less than,
and I didn't know if it was gonna work.
I was,
was terrified that I'd find out it
wasn't and then I would have to stop
running as much.
And at the time I was like,
that doesn't sound like what I want to
do.
So,
um,
this was just something I decided to
explore first.
Um,
and it's,
it's really goofy because like I've
certainly evolved and kind of how I use
it from that.
When I first started,
when I,
when I first started,
I went like really kind of really low
carb.
Like that clinical ketosis level where
you read about where they're like 50
grams of carbohydrates are last.
And,
you know,
I did that for about,
I think it was like four to six weeks
and,
um,
I didn't have as hard of a time as what
I think I've,
I've,
I've seen some people have with it.
You know,
you have people talking about everything
from what the Keto flu to just like
feeling really lethargic for awhile
before that kind of metabolic switch
flips.
Um,
what I kind of noticed was,
um,
I felt really good doing like really
like low level type mundane task,
just like day to day work and things
like that.
But like maybe every second or third day
I'd go for a run and just feel awful.
And,
um,
I kind of knew enough about it that I
thought,
okay,
let's give this a solid four weeks
before I make any judgments on whether
that's going to be something that sticks
around or not.
And you know,
after about that point,
my energy level's kind of normalized.
Um,
and then,
you know,
I was,
so at that point I was like excited.
I was like,
this is sweet and well,
I should have mentioned too,
like during that process I started
sleeping through the night again,
which was like kind of really an eye
opening thing for me.
Um,
because usually like I'd wake up at
least three times.
What do you attribute that to?
Um,
you know,
I,
I don't know for sure of,
but,
uh,
you know,
it could be anything from just the
amount of stress I was causing on my
body from kind of two angles from the
training plus like,
you know,
like I don't want to demonize
carbohydrates because I think they have
a place,
I think they're a great tool.
I just think like,
the,
the question everyone should ask is at
what level do they become kind of a
margin to diminishing returns for you.
And you know,
what I think was likely happening is
that,
you know,
I was reaching past that margin at
diminishing returns and,
um,
it was causing more stress than what my
body was,
was able to tolerate and that was
causing cortisol spikes or something
like that,
that was waking me up at night.
Um,
but you know,
who knows really like it's a,
it all I know is the only thing at that
time I changed because my diet,
and we should probably point out that
this is not universal,
that everybody's diet is going to affect
them differently for sure.
Fine with carbohydrates.
Use a lot of people out there that,
you know,
high carbohydrate diet and they have
zero issues with it whatsoever.
And it's,
that's one of the weirdest things about
people,
you know,
that we are so variable depending upon
your ancestry,
you know,
what part of the world that they
evolved.
Yeah.
It's,
it's fascinating to me because I mean,
I'll look at,
folks are doing complete opposite of why
am and there they're doing just fine.
Um,
and it's,
you know,
then I'll look at some folks too that
are doing the opposite of me and they're
doing just fine for a while and then
they ultimately start noticing the same
kind of things I did and then they can
clean it up.
Uh,
so it is kind of it,
I think at the end of the day you just
gotta be kind of honest with yourself.
And you know,
some people I think are really,
really robust and they can,
they can hit their body with that high
octane fuel of carbohydrate like day in
and day out at a high level.
And it doesn't seem to bother him much.
But you know,
other people I've yet think just that it
can kind of,
it's like playing with rocket fuel a
little bit where you know,
a little bit can be great and not too
much of it can kind of burn you up a
little bit.
So you're saying that you started off at
like 50 grams of carbohydrates a day,
the grills trick,
Ketosis Diet,
what did you eventually move to?
Um,
it,
so the way I call,
as I peered eyes it,
so like when I look at my year,
you're,
you can pick out a week where I'm kind
of in peak training and then pick out a
week where I'm kind of in like a
recovery phase or off season.
And it looks like two completely
different lifestyles.
So my first thought after kind of like
working through the cold ketogenic
approach,
um,
cause I should add too,
like,
um,
once I got like feeling good about that,
I started adding back speed workouts and
things like that and I definitely
noticed that I was missing kind of that
last year.
Like it was a lot more difficult to go
out and really throttle down.
Like I could run all day at a slow pace.
But if I decided to go out on the track
and do like 400 meter repeats at like a
really fast,
like a really fast pace,
um,
it was really hard to kind of,
to be able to do that.
That's a common complaint.
Robb Wolf,
you know Rob,
Oh rob wolf had a similar issue.
He's gotten like very heavily into
Jujitsu and he was telling me that he
just can't stick to that 50 grams of
carbohydrates a day and still have the
energy to go hard.
Does,
does,
do you notice robb wolf work out more
than one time a day?
I do not know.
Um,
he looked very fit though.
I'm not sure what his,
uh,
what his schedule is,
but I know he works out very hard and if
he's doing Jujitsu,
this is really,
it's very difficult to do Jujitsu any
other way than hard.
Sure.
Yet he says one thing I've always been
curious about too and you know,
I'm not,
I'm not trying to come,
come on here and say like everyone
should switch to doing what I do.
I mean I think you should follow your
own your own set,
your own personal self and if it'd be
honest with yourself,
you feel great,
do what you're doing.
If you don't then probably look to
change something.
But like one thing I'm always looking at
nower suspecting is that like it's more
about the recovery between efforts than
it is about the intensity of the effort
or the duration of the effort in terms
of how much carbs you need to bring back
or want to bring back.
Because I've also had circumstances
where like I'll do like a big workout or
a race or something like that and then
I'll go really easy for like a week and
during that week I'll go like super
strict to Quito.
Um,
cause I'm recovering,
I'm not doing anything intense,
I'm not doing anything too long.
Um,
so that's,
that's the point in my training where I
kind of say,
all right,
let's get rid of the start the fast
acting fuel sources.
I don't need them right now.
And reset that whole fat adaptation
thing.
You feel like you,
the fast acting fuel sources of
carbohydrates,
you only really need them when you're
pushing hard,
right?
When you're really running fast.
Yeah.
And I actually think it's,
it's when you're doubling down on those
on a regular basis.
So like if you're working out really
hard for like 45 minutes to an hour a
day,
I think you can probably get away with
almost a ketogenic or like a really low
carbohydrate approach because you're
giving yourself like 23 plus hours
between sessions for your body to kind
of a restock glycogen stores from other
areas.
Like,
you know,
from fat and proteins and things like
that.
I think when you start getting into a
system where you're like,
myself,
I'm doing two days a lot,
and then sometimes one of those is a
speed session.
That's when I feel like I need to bring
some of the carbohydrate back.
And I think it's probably just to get
some of the glycogen and a little faster
rate because that is going to replenish
your glycogen stores faster as a
carbohydrate then like a fat or a
protein probably would.
So how many grams of carbohydrates to do
with having to deal with that?
Um,
when I'm in like peak training,
which is about 20 hours a week of
running strength training and mobility
type stuff,
you know,
I'll probably let myself get up to like
15 to 25% of my intake from
carbohydrate.
Um,
what do you think that is in grams a
flu?
It probably,
it depends a lot on like what I actually
do because I don't count calories very
often.
I used to just to Kinda like see what
was going on and then I kinda got
intuitive with it.
Uh,
Graham Wise,
you know,
it's probably anywhere from like two to
300 maybe.
And then when I'm in those phases of
training,
it's really intense in terms of like
just a,
or I shouldn't say intense,
it's just really tedious and the amount
of time and energy required for it now
or you blood monitoring at the time you
checking your millimolar?
I am sometimes like when I'm like,
when I get curious about that type of
stuff or I've done it in the past.
I've actually,
what I did originally is I got the blood
ketone monitor and they also got one of
those key tonics.
But like it's like this little usb thing
and then you blow into it.
And is that accurate?
Um,
I think there's,
I think there's varied results.
I think they've gotten a lot better with
it.
Um,
but what I did is I actually measured my
blood ketone and then I would use that
and I tried to find kind of like if mine
was matching what that thing would say.
So I kind of had an,
I got it to where I kind of had an idea
of where certain ranges on that thing
would kind of indicate whether I was in
Ketosis or not.
Um,
so like I very much is coming out of
ketosis during peak training.
Like when I would,
especially when I would get up to two,
300 grams of carbohydrate,
I would come out of ketosis.
Uh,
and I probably go back into ketosis
throughout that,
for that phase.
And when you said go back in and come
out,
like what kind of time period are you
talking about?
Uh,
it,
the time period was more indicative
about what I kind of ate during it too.
Like if I did,
if,
if I did or I shouldn't say what I like,
how I kind of structured those two to
300 grams of carbohydrate.
Like if I did like a big bolus of it in
one meal,
I'd get back into ketosis a little
quicker because then I wouldn't come
back to the carbohydrates again for a
while.
Very inside the day.
Yeah.
Like,
I would still like if I,
and here's where it got kind of
interesting I guess is I do a lot of my,
the heaviest bulk of my training in the
morning.
So I typically wake up and have some
coffee with like coconut milk or heavy
whipping cream or something like that.
And then,
uh,
you know,
go for my run.
So then when I get back from a run,
you know,
it might be two hours,
sometimes even three.
And,
uh,
you know,
at that point I had just slept for eight
to 10 hours.
Then,
you know,
by the time we got done with my run,
I hadn't had probably had an e I had
essentially done like a small
intermittent fast for the most part.
Um,
so like,
even when I had the higher amounts of
carbohydrates,
I'd find myself going back into the coat
ketosis at the end of something like
that sometimes.
Um,
but really it was,
to me,
it wasn't necessarily a question of
whether I was in Ketosis or not because
that really wasn't important to me.
Um,
like it's is important.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And what I wanted out of this approach
was,
um,
I wanted to be able to rely on my body
to body to burn high levels of fat when
I needed it to.
But I also wanted to be metabolically
flexible enough where if I needed to hit
the gas pedal,
I could do that as well.
Um,
and I think that's where people get a
little uh,
uh,
confused are up in arms or something
because there's not a whole lot of
studies that kind of look at that
specifically.
Like,
can you do that or can you not do that?
Some people think it's kind of an all or
nothing thing where you either get
really fat adapted or you get really
carved dependence and then everything
else is kind of like,
you know,
this gray area that you can't really get
into.
But that's not my experience.
My experience has been that like I can
get the cure,
here's my kind of litmus test.
If I can go out for like a four hour,
even five hour run with no fuel other
than water and electrolytes,
then I'm fat adapted enough.
I don't need to get any more fat adapted
than that because I can eat during the
race and everyone else is going to be,
so like,
I don't really need to get more fat
adapted that from a performance
standpoint.
Um,
so when I get to that point,
then it's like,
how many,
how many carbohydrates can I bring back
to kind of give me that extra nudge or
that extra fuel substrate.
Um,
have you ever tried mixing exogenous
ketones with carbohydrates?
Um,
not,
was talking about that and doing
steroids.
It was incredible.
Yeah.
He's,
he's a maniac.
He's a maniac yet there's a,
who else was it?
Was it dominic d'agostino is playing
around with that stuff quite a bit too,
or he might've helped.
Uh,
he might've helped,
uh,
with the,
the creation of some of that stuff.
I know there was a,
I'd have to look back in my emails and
stuff,
but I actually had a,
there was a guy who was doing a real
clinical version of the exaggerators
ketones and,
um,
he had sent me one a while back to kind
of do a little test for him.
And,
uh,
it was like just this little canister of
exaggerates ketone and you wanted me to
kind of check my ketones when I woke up
in the morning,
take that test at 15 minutes later and
then test again after my run a ketone
ester.
Yeah,
I think so.
Super potent stuff.
Taste like Dick Matt Brown brought some
of that in and it's like woo.
Yet,
did you test your ketones when you took
it at her?
No,
I did and I didn't have a monitor on me,
but it tasted terrible.
But I felt great after it was over.
And you have to take it with a glucose.
Yeah.
See I think that's,
maybe that's where I messed up.
But uh,
um,
besides that,
like my ketone levels shot up.
I woke up that morning,
I think I was at like 1.0 millimoles or
something like that.
I took that exogenous ketone,
um,
and 15 minutes later and I test I was a
3.7 millimoles.
Wow.
So it was like,
okay,
stuff works.
Yeah,
it worked.
But I don't know.
Here's what I,
here's my question is with that stuff
from a performance standpoint is like
it's people are looking at that kind of,
I think more like an light where it's
like I take this on top of my energy
source,
whereas that's actually an energy
a fairly potent one to.
So like when I'm out there racing and
I'm trying to kind of limit,
I'm not trying to eat a certain amount
so that I kind of keep that energy where
I want it,
but I'm also trying not to go overboard
because I don't want digestive stress.
Um,
that's interesting.
So like as you're running,
you have to maintain like a certain
amount of food and your system,
but you don't want to have a large meal.
Yeah,
yeah.
Cause like basically the way it seemed
to simply put it like digestion requires
blood volume,
you know,
to move into your gut and like digest
the food.
So when you're running,
especially when it's hot,
your body is also trying to use your,
your blood volume for muscle function
and cooling and things like that.
So by kind of introducing another use
for that blood volume,
your body's probably is running out of
resources to kind of make all those
things run smoothly.
Um,
which is why a lot of times an ultra
marathons people find out,
like they have the worst luck with like
throwing up and stomach issues when it
gets really hot out because their body's
got to go double down on the cooling
side of things with the blood volume.
And then it's like,
well,
something's got to give.
So it just picks up everything you put
in your stomach.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
is there a way to medicate that,
uh,
eat less?
That's it.
So when you,
if you're running like,
what's the size portion?
Like what do you,
what would you say if you're doing a
hundred miler?
Yeah.
And you have to pause for fuel.
Um,
you know,
I'll,
I'll typically aim for around a hundred
to 200 calories an hour when I'm doing
an doing a hundred miler.
And to kind of put that in perspective.
When I was a high carb,
I was aiming for three,
four,
and sometimes even 500 calories an hour.
So when I kind of went into the approach
where fat was my primary fuel source,
the the need for that carbohydrate
essentially got cut in half if not more.
And for me that's a win.
As long as energy levels are the same
because it means I have to eat less
during the race as one last logistic
thing,
one less potential stomach issue.
Um,
so what,
what's a typical meal?
A typical meal like when you're running?
Oh,
while I'm running,
I,
you know,
I usually stick to like,
uh,
um,
like water based stuff.
So like I'll use a product called,
um,
x endurance fuel five,
and it's essentially like a really,
really high level sports drink,
um,
with like a varying,
it's got,
it's,
it's carbohydrate based and I can tell
you why I use carbohydrates instead of
fats during a race in a minute too if
you want.
Um,
but it's like five different types of
kind of that release at varying points.
So you get some that's kind of a little
quick jolt and others that are more
sustained,
like kind of like a sweet potato type of
a release.
Um,
so I'll be just trickling that in.
So like if I'm doing like a hundred
miler and let's say I'm aiming for like
30 to 40 ounces of water,
uh,
per hour to kind of stay on top of
hydration,
I'll put,
um,
you know,
to like a hundred to 200 calories with
that stuff in that water.
So then I'm kind of killing two birds
with one stone and getting my fuel in as
well as hydrating at the same time.
So what,
and why you taking carbohydrates while
you're running instead of fats?
Yeah.
So that's,
that's the other thing like in,
and I see this as,
as somewhat of a,
I don't know if it's an issue
necessarily,
but it's an interesting thing for that
at the very least is when you,
when I talked to folks who are like
really into the high fat approach,
you know,
some of them are like zero carb or like
really ketogenic all the time,
24,
seven.
Uh,
there'll be taking in like fat sources
during a race.
And I've never understood that.
Um,
just because when you look at your
body's energy systems during a race,
like you have your glycogen stores and
then you have body fat and I think a lot
of people kind of get misled and they
think,
oh,
I'm a really lean runner so I can't rely
on body fat.
When in reality,
even the leanest endurance athletes have
enough body fat to get through an
endurance race.
Like even if your 4% 5% body fat at your
leanest you,
that's a much bigger fuel source then
your glycogen reserves.
So when I'm doing a race,
I've got enough fat to take care of the
fat metabolizing portion of that energy,
a requirement for the race.
What I might run out of is those
glycogen stores,
which are really small in comparison.
So I'm trying to just slowly trickle in
the,
the sugar or the carbohydrate during a
race.
I'm just enough to kind of keep my
glycogen stores where I want to be so I
can hit the gas if I need to.
Um,
but not at the level where it's going to
cost stomach distress or compromise or
heavily compromised.
My body's like willingness or ability to
burn fat either.
That's fascinating.
So like as you're running,
your body could switch back and forth
between fats and carbohydrates because
you're so fat adapted.
Yeah.
And I,
you know,
it's actually probably happening like
simultaneously,
it's just that different rates like,
like someone who's really fat adapted,
they could be running kind of the same
effort and the fat after person might be
like burning 80% fat,
20% carbohydrate and the carb dependent
person might be like a 50,
50 split.
So that carved dependent person is going
to exhaust our glycogen stores a lot
quicker or they're going to have to fuel
themselves at a much higher rate to make
up for that deficit.
And um,
when you look at like how difficult that
is,
cause you know,
some of these,
especially some of these mountain races
where you're running uphill,
it's like you,
you might be burning 800 plus calories
an hour and it's really hard.
I'm all right.
Yeah.
Uh Huh.
And it's really hard to replace that on
the fly if you have those running uphill
one.
So I would think that's a much more
difficult race.
Yeah,
I mean it's a different setup.
It's,
you know,
it's one of those things where I'm
pretty new to that actually.
Like,
um,
most of my ultra running career folks,
moral flat stuff.
And part of that just because I've lived
in a lot of flat areas and like I was
kind of saying earlier,
if you really want to nail race you have
to be specific.
So I learned kind of early,
probably around like 2013 or so.
That was in my best interest to make my
peak racist flat ones if I really wanted
to meet my full potential.
Um,
now I live in Phoenix,
so I've got a lot more access to
mountains.
You,
I can get on the trails and the and do
some significant climbing right out my
back door.
So,
um,
I've certainly been able to practice
that more and as I've gotten more
competent at it,
I do recognize like,
oh,
it's not quite as hard as I thought it
was originally because I was going into
it essentially.
Undertrained whereas now it's like I go
into it,
I'm like,
Oh,
I'm,
I'm more adjusted to this.
So I mean,
it's still hard.
Like going uphill is hard no matter how
you skin it,
but it's like,
it's one of those things where if you
kind of figure out the pace,
it shouldn't be any more hard.
Like it should be just as hard to run
flat because you're going to have to run
faster.
Um,
and it's just,
then it just comes down to I think,
the right training and,
you know,
pacing everything.
Right.
So interesting.
You're saying you're living in Phoenix,
do you run the summer in Phoenix because
Phoenix is fucking insanely hot.
So I moved there in January.
So good wake up call comes,
you're like,
whoa.
Yeah,
it'll be,
it'll be warm.
Um,
I actually kinda like it because right
now I'm training for the western states
100 and that's in,
it starts in squaw valley and ends in
Auburn,
California.
Uh,
and they go through like these four
canyons that get,
can get brutally hot,
like 110 plus some years.
Um,
and like it's like a vest.
We have water bottles attached to or
anything.
Yup.
Yeah.
That stuff has come such a long way
since I started the sport.
I remember when I first started it was
pretty primitive type stuff.
And now the,
the sport is,
I think through hiking plays a big role
in this too has gotten so popular,
are popular enough where now companies
are really tight dialing that stuff in
where you can get like a pack,
um,
that just sits nice and snug on you.
And you can put what like I use,
I use a brand called Nathan and they
have like ones have bladders on the back
where they also have ones that you can
put water bottles on the front.
Um,
and then just,
you know,
different setups and stuff.
So,
so yeah,
that's like a must in,
I mean,
he,
even in early mornings,
it's got to be brutal in Phoenix.
Right?
Yeah.
Uh,
I mean I have yet to see the worst of
it.
Why did you move there?
Uh,
well,
part of it was,
um,
I want to carry a gun.
Well,
I'm looking at,
well,
I moved from Sacramento,
so let's say I'm looking into that now.
But yeah,
so it's,
um,
it was,
it was a combination of things for me.
Like,
uh,
I'm trying to kind of balance a few
different things.
I,
I train a lot.
I also work for one of my primary
sponsors,
ultra footwear,
uh,
and like for me to be able to kind of do
this stuff for them that I was wanting
to do,
it made more sense to be in Phoenix,
just be product testing and stuff like
that.
Yeah.
That,
and just like putting on like,
like small group runs and events and
things like that in the area.
Uh,
like if I wanted to invest or if I
wanted to kind of appropriately handled
the territory,
phoenix made a lot more sense in
sacramento.
Northern California has just grown so
much for that company in the last couple
of years that they needed to get someone
in there who's going to do full time
plus to really cover the area.
Um,
and then I,
you know,
I also got engaged in,
in January as well.
So,
uh,
um,
my fiance,
she,
she was best served being in the Phoenix
area too,
so it was kind of a mutual,
uh,
she was from Dallas originally and
Phoenix was kind of like a,
a mutually good spot for both of us.
So,
uh,
um,
we,
we both kind of looked at it as like,
well,
what do we want?
And it was,
we want trails right in our backyard,
but we also want access to flat stuff.
And we,
we actually kind of want the heat
because it like,
there's races where you need that to
train for.
So when it gets hot earlier,
you can prepare for them.
A much easy reason to move to Phoenix.
I'm enjoying the heat for training.
Well,
I'm not even the craziest one in the
house.
My,
my fiance's a savage.
She,
yeah,
her name is Nicole Calla dropless.
She like,
you know how like,
I thought,
I've always thought I'm a hard worker
and someone who like puts a lot of time
and effort and the things I do.
And then I met her and,
uh,
you know,
I like took,
she's,
she's cut from the Jackal cloth,
let's put it that way.
Right.
So,
yeah,
she'll do like,
she,
she works for a company called Towers
Watson.
Um,
and uh,
Kinda does a,
manages the Midwest division for like
stuffs.
So she'll be on like a conference call
with Amazon and then,
you know,
go out and run three hours after that
and then come back and get on another
conference call and just keeps going and
going and going.
So,
yeah,
it's,
uh,
it,
it was,
it made sense for her job and my job to
kind of be in Phoenix and with as busy
as she is and as busy as I can get from
time to time,
like it's nice to be able to go out your
backyard and be on the trail five
minutes later.
Whereas both of us didn't have that
before.
We both had to drive to get to any kind
of trail,
especially her dallas.
It was a lot of,
it's just like flat road running in her
area.
So um,
to helps us him hardly any hills.
No,
no,
you will.
And that's,
that's,
that's what is impressive with like,
so she's done western states a few
times.
The race,
I was telling him before the canyons and
I,
she's been sixth place there twice,
just training on flat roads,
basically.
Crazy.
Does she do anything to augment that?
Like doing lunges or anything like that?
Uh,
she does,
uh,
some strength work and stuff,
but really in a lot of it was just,
you know,
she would go out and run and run a lot
and then I'm sure like she hasn't met
her full potential at that specific
event or certainly like mountain type
races just because she wasn't trained in
mountains.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
And she's,
she's good though.
So like,
I mean,
she was a division one recruit for
college and stuff back in the day.
So like,
and she's got some rung talent,
no doubt.
Um,
and then she puts in the work is
consistency is a huge thing.
Like if you can't find the specific
stuff and you're really geeked about a
specific race,
like I don't think not having the right
training environment as a reason to not
do it if you're excited to do it.
Um,
so like for her,
she was more excited to get out on the
trails and she wants to go,
you know,
do something on a track or a flat road.
Like I was,
so for her it was like,
even if I'm not quite where I would like
to be,
I'm going to do it anyway.
Now I'm not familiar with ultra
footwear,
but what I wanted to ask you is,
does anybody wear like minimalist shoes
and run these ultra marathons?
Yeah,
yeah.
There was,
uh,
there was actually a Gal,
I cannot remember her name,
this is a couple of years ago who ran
ultras in um,
those vibram fivefingers yeah,
yeah.
And a trail stuff too.
So,
um,
you know,
it must have been a beast.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
hard to run just a couple miles.
Yeah.
And it's,
you know,
it's interesting because so ultra
footwear made the shoe this last year
called uh,
the,
the vanish and it's essentially a
minimalist shoe.
I'm just like a little bit of fabric on
the top.
Super,
super hard flat base.
And that's kind of what I like when I'm
on a road or a track.
Um,
so I was wearing that,
the vanish vanish.
Yeah.
Pull that up and see what that looks
like.
And it's a,
so I went to this,
this,
this ultra race,
and I wore those thinking I'm going to
have the lightest shoe out of anyone
here.
Three guys show up running completely
barefoot.
Why?
He ran an ultra marathons barefoot.
Yeah,
he had to,
that's another level.
There was one,
there was one guy who is Christ.
He's like a to 22 or 23 marathoner and
he's barefoot.
And he said that he like runs a marathon
bear,
so he doesn't do the marathon barefoot.
He actually said that,
uh,
the,
that's a little bit of padding in that
it looks like we're less,
there's a lip on the outside.
Is that the vantage or is that it's his
vantage point.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So I mean there's,
there's a little bit,
there's like a,
it like a carbon fiber plate and you see
where that little cut is in there.
There's like a carbon fiber plate in
there that makes it a little more firm.
So when I'm looking for in a shoe and
I'm looking for kind of like that
natural feel is something that's got to
affirm its soul or affirm durometer
because like I don't want to squish down
into the shoe.
I want to pop right off the ground.
Um,
and I think like really like that is
just,
I mean you've probably experienced this
with the,
with the vibrams where like,
um,
if you spend the time,
your foot feet gets stronger and
stronger and stronger and it's only a
matter of time before they get strong.
If you've got to keep kind of working at
it,
just like a weight lifter,
you know,
when they start out weightlifting,
they're nowhere near where they are 10
years later.
Um,
so like for me,
back in 2012 I think I kind of like,
you know,
I read born to run and I've even heard
of the book.
Yeah,
I've heard some amazing,
yeah.
You know,
I,
I read that and I was like,
this is intriguing,
you know,
and it made a lot of sense too.
It's like,
you know,
if we were meant to have a wedge on our
heel,
like we would have had a wedge on our
heel.
Yeah.
No that's,
that's a ridiculous thing that Nike came
up with.
And it's really unfortunate that so many
people have adopted that and they've
run,
he'll first like that.
Yeah.
Well and the problem I think too is that
like the shoe is essentially a cast for
your foot.
Even even that vanish that I had up
there,
a little cast compared to what you're
normally going to see,
but it's still a cast.
That's why I liked those five fingers
cause there's nothing,
this is a very,
very flexible,
Robbie's a rubber underneath and it's a
glove for your,
for your feet.
Yeah.
And you know,
people just don't know that.
I think that you can really work those
foot muscles to a point where you can
exhaust them the way you would in a
shoe.
Um,
it just takes a lot of time cause like
if I broke my arm,
put a cast on it and then like six,
eight weeks later got the cast taken
off,
I went back in the weight room and did a
normal routine,
I would be wrecked the next day.
So when you take your foot out of that
shoe cast,
you have it in or take it out of the
position it's gotten used to and put it
in a different position,
it's like taking a cast off and trying
to do that full mode of mode of a
training or motion.
So like you know,
I when I first kind of got an ultra
running,
I,
I I worked my way down to a minimal
issue.
I spent probably six months before I was
running exclusively and something that
was um,
really minimalist.
And when I say minimalist,
I mean zero drop and no cushion or
little to no cushion.
Cause I think some people confuse that
too.
Like that the shoe you saw up there
cause was like,
oh it looks like it's got a little bit
of padding there.
So that's like zero drop with cushioning
or that she really doesn't have a lot of
cushioning,
but,
um,
there are shoes that ultra makes.
It does.
And what that does is it takes you from,
like the way I describe is this is
someone in like a,
um,
someone in a traditional running shoe,
real built up cushion.
A lot of support is on one in a spectrum
barefoot runner.
Like those dudes that I ran into at the
track,
um,
they're on the other end of the
spectrum.
There's all the steps in between to get
to that.
So like,
I can't believe people run ultras
barefoot.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
I don't think there's too many periods
this fucking savage.
I look at this dude barefoot.
Ted.
The Sandal.
Yeah.
Is it a sandal?
Hmm.
Well that it wasn't that in the born to
one that these guys had made sandals out
of tires.
Yeah.
Uh Huh.
I've been using something called a pull
up,
this Vivo Vivo Barefoot.
I've been using these.
Um,
what I like about these is that I don't
have to look where I step.
There's no cushioning at all.
The trail one,
I'll use that one.
The far left,
the far left.
Yeah,
that run.
Um,
there's no cushion to it,
but it's got some tread and the bottom
is hard enough so that I could run on
hard rocks and then I don't think about
it.
It's hard to tell in that image how
little there is underneath it.
But there's a,
there's nothing going on in terms of
like there's no squished to it at all to
just some good size knobs.
So you have,
uh,
some good,
um,
some good tread,
you know,
so you can,
you can get good traction and dirt and
mud and stuff like that.
They weighed nothing
that's,
yeah.
And you know,
it's normal that thing up to your foot
muscles are flexing every which way
they,
yeah.
That's cool.
It's made a big difference with me,
man.
But honestly to five fingers are
probably the best for that.
They just don't have as much traction
and I have to look where I'm stepping,
you know,
like I have to be careful like sharp
rocks and stuff.
I have to look down.
Don't step on that one.
I'll look around.
I don't like looking it just run with
those.
I can just run.
Just flow through it.
Yeah,
you can get a faster pace with those
[inaudible].
Yeah,
and that's,
that's,
that's where I kind of draw the line too
is like when I'm on the roads and on the
track,
I don't mind having that like no cushion
type of thing.
But then when I go on like the trails
and Phoenix,
it's very rocky and hard and then I'll
use like a shoe called the king empty.
That's kind of like the one that you had
there.
It's a little less nimble I would say.
Then that one,
but it's got that,
that like really aggressive lug.
It's got the foot shape,
toe box,
so I don't feel like my feet are getting
pinch together.
What do you think barefoot Ted does on
like on the trails?
I was trails.
I think he probably wears those sandals
probably,
right?
Yeah.
Just something where it's just something
that keeps him forgetting.
Cut.
Yeah.
But there are guys who just do that
barefoot to fuck.
I think they're very few,
but it's,
it's,
it's doable.
Have you ever see that show dual
survivor?
It's one of those wacky survivor shows.
I don't know if I've seen that one.
This one guy,
I think his name's corey,
who has the most disgusting fee I've
ever seen in my life.
Almost as disgusting as that one guy was
cutting the bottom of feet off and
feeding into dog.
That guy with the knife.
Yeah.
That video's awful to watch.
But a,
this guy walks barefoot everywhere and
his idea is like,
do you gotta toughen your feet up?
Because you might not have to have
shoes.
You know,
they,
they get real crazy with this whole
survival,
this then,
so this guy is basically has,
I'm not joking,
like a good solid half inch of callous
under his entire foot.
Yeah.
It's amazing what the human body will do
when you put it in a position to need
to.
Yeah.
Well it has to adapt.
I mean,
that's one of the reasons why I'm
fascinated by guys like you,
these ultra runners is because the,
for the average person,
that's an impossible feat.
But you've built,
there's that guy's foot.
Look at that dude.
What ends up fuck it looks like elephant
skin.
Yeah,
it's fucking gnarly.
Um,
but the guys like you have adapted your
body to this position where,
you know,
you can do that and it's just a matter
of putting in the training runs and
making sure you're fueling up correctly.
And,
you know,
a hundred mile race is not a question
whether or not you could do it.
It's how fast he could do it.
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's interesting,
the cool thing in this,
Michael,
back to what you asked,
like why ultra marathons,
and I think it is part of it too is like
in a hundred miles,
it's almost like it's not a matter of
when is something going to go wrong.
It's,
um,
or I should say,
if something's gonna go wrong,
it's a matter of when and how do you
respond to it.
So it's a typical thing that goes wrong.
Um,
you know,
I think a lot of people will have like
cramping or they'll,
they'll bonk,
I mean this is one of the reasons why I
love the high fat approach is because
like bonking from the light energy side
of things is essentially nonexistent
explained bunkie too.
People don't know where you talk.
So,
so bonking is essentially what happens
and it's,
it's,
I think it's actually more common in the
marathon just because people are running
a lot faster in those.
But essentially what's is you're
depleting your glycogen stores to the
point where your body doesn't really
have access to that fuel substrate
anymore.
And if you are trying,
if you're not good at metabolizing fat
or you cannot burn fat at a high rate,
at a decent clip,
a grinds to a halt and you see people
staggering and falling over,
losing her mind,
hallucinating and stuff like that in
those situations.
Um,
so like,
you know,
banking is something that is,
is an issue with ultra marathon because
you're out there for so long.
If you get behind on fueling,
you know,
you could bonk and stuff like that.
So,
you know,
part of the reason,
and I talked about before with like,
there's a lot of logistics with an ultra
marathon and there's all these variables
are just,
just,
just so prevalent when you're out there
that long that if you can eliminate some
of those are reduced,
the potential then flaring up,
that's usually a wind cause then there's
less chance of something popping up that
you wouldn't expect or an uncertain
thing happening during the race.
And,
but they still happen.
You know,
I've done the,
I would say the most efficient hundred
miler I've done is,
uh,
when I,
I ran 11 hours and 40 minutes and 55
seconds at a race in 2015 called Holy
Shit.
You bet you ran a hundred miles in 11
hours.
Yeah,
that was,
that was on a trip.
That was one on the track in a Spec of a
fuck.
That's crazy.
Ran a 11 hours.
You were at a hundred miles.
Yeah.
So I think the thing that,
how long does it take to drive a hundred
miles?
Okay.
It takes it.
I mean,
if you go a hundred miles an hour,
it takes an hour to me longer to get to
the airport.
If the traffic on the five how's that
bitter?
Broke the US 100 mile record.
You average seven fucking minutes per
mile for almost 12 hours.
Dude,
that is insane.
That is fucking insane.
Bert Kreischer,
he brags when he runs 70 minute files
for like three miles.
What did,
what did burdened up running that?
The La Marathon in six and a half.
Six and a half.
I think it was close to that.
Yeah,
it's going to shorter than that.
I think it was five,
five or something.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
Ours.
Dad.
Yeah,
he's fucking JV.
Well,
I'll say,
I'll say this here,
bird,
if you're listening,
contact me.
I'll get you to four and a half in six
months.
You're challenge is Zach fucking man.
If he tells you you can do it,
that is,
that is an incredible number that you
broke the u s 100 mile record by running
seven fucking minutes per mile.
It's,
it's,
that's crazy.
The thing.
And the interesting thing I thought
about that event was when I was talking
about efficiency is I stopped twice
during that race and it was for maybe a
total of like 60 at most 90 seconds
total.
And it was just,
it was just a p two times.
Do you have a thought about just pee in
your pants and just keep running?
Well,
black shorts party rolling.
There was a guy who did that.
Uh,
it was two years before I did that race
and he was trying to break 13 hours and
he was like right on the edge.
I mean,
he just whipped it out and peed
all over the track,
I'm pretty sure.
Okay.
What would he put his penis on?
Pants.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I mean,
I think that's probably what I would do.
And um,
it's uh,
uh,
that guy dude,
he did himself well.
Everyone who's been doing endurance
sport long enough,
we'll have,
have a situation like that
unfortunately.
Got Him of his legs.
He must've just exploded last.
It must have been a bomb bomb went off.
Oof.
Yeah.
It's,
you know,
it's,
it's okay to poop your pants does a
sign,
is that him with the same guy?
Different person.
It's very a sensitive subject for folks.
Yeah.
Your parents.
It's,
it's a,
it's a running joke in the endurance
running community though.
Cause if you do it long enough to spend,
probably happen to eventually passed it.
Right.
And I would imagine you're running a
hundred miles and your body's gonna.
There's gonna be misfires for sure.
How do you time your meals?
Like before you run it,
like say if you're going to run a
hundred miles,
what is your last meal before you get
there?
Yeah,
so I'll eat a big dinner the night
before,
probably around like four or five
o'clock.
And what would that be?
Um,
so I'll do like a huge steak.
Uh,
I try to keep 16 ounces,
20 ounces at least 1620 is probably a
pretty good number.
140 pounds give or take a lot of fucking
meat.
That's crazy.
Well,
this is where it gets fascinating with
the lifestyle thing I was telling you
about is like there's days during the
year where like I'm in training where
I'm metabolizing two to three times my
resting metabolic rate.
So I've got to feed myself appropriately
for that.
Um,
and that means a lot of stake.
Wow.
So was that your primary food source?
Um,
I don't know if I'd say stake for sure,
but definitely fatty meat sources.
Um,
a lot of like,
uh,
like saturated fat based oils like
coconut oil,
like Geeky,
that sort of thing.
Um,
but yeah,
I don't,
I don't shy away from meat.
I usually have meat or eggs for every
meal for the most part.
And interesting in every meal I should
say.
Yeah.
There's a lot of talk lately about the
Carnivore Diet.
There's a lot of people that are delving
into that,
including Jordan Peterson's daughter,
which is a really interesting case
because she had severe autoimmune
disorder.
Like she had some severe issues with
like horrible arthritis where she's had,
um,
I know she's had hip replacements and
that believe she's having an ankle
replaced soon too.
Okay.
Like,
she's like severe issues and if she eats
anything other than me,
it flares up horribly.
It's really crazy.
I've never,
I'm not going to,
I want to try to talk to her,
maybe even get her in here.
But,
um,
I,
I've never heard anything like that.
I thought I heard somewhere.
Um,
it was after the last time you had
Jordan on where he was telling you about
how he just basically he meets in
Greens.
Where was on his daughter's
recommendation?
Yeah,
I think he's cut out all vegetables
right now for at least a trial.
I thought I saw something about that.
Um,
but yeah,
it's,
it's one of those things where I think
like some,
it's like what I was saying before,
like why I don't necessarily want people
to say like,
well Zach is saying everyone should do
exactly what he's doing
and then,
you know,
they,
that's important to bring up.
Everybody's body is different for sure.
I mean to the point where like you have
people like that,
like when I had issues I were having
were incredibly minor compared to the
Jordan Peterson's daughter.
Like,
like,
I mean,
she's in a spot where,
you know,
she had to make changes if she wanted to
even just probably do daily activities.
Um,
and you know,
that's that,
that's I think the hard part for people
to kind of understand is like,
there people are at different stages of
that.
Some people,
like no one's breaking themselves
overnight.
So it's like this is something that's
chipping away at people and sometimes it
chips away at them quicker and some
people and it takes longer for others.
Uh,
so if you have an issue like that,
it's like you almost have to go back to
square one and say,
what are,
give me a couple things that I know
aren't going to upset me.
And let's start from there and see if we
can start adding things back eventually.
Maybe.
Or,
um,
you know,
we,
uh,
you know Sean Baker you had on the
podcast,
we actually started recording some
podcasts together and um,
we are having this gal come on who's
been a carnival for eight years and she
was kind of in that situation where she
had a whole bunch of goofy things going
on even with the Quito Protocol and she
eventually just cut everything up with
meat and has been doing great ever
since.
That's a vegans nightmare and things
like that.
Like,
well,
yeah,
I just wish people could separate their
ideology from the reality of certain
people's bodies.
And,
and unfortunately,
and this is very,
unfortunately,
you've got a separate,
also all your,
all the horrors that we associate with
factory farming and all the other things
that we associate with meat and meat
consumption,
those things are real and terrible and
he absolutely should be avoided in
absolutely factory farmers should be
illegal.
I mean,
I think it's one of the great horrors of
modern society.
I really,
really do.
But take that away.
And you know,
some people don't think animals should
die at all,
but they don't live forever.
And other animals eat them and it's just
like this is just a part of life.
Then you're into health and whether or
not consuming meat is actually healthy
and there's no evidence that it's not,
there's none.
Yeah.
You know the thing that like I want a
Vegan to sit me down and explained to me
is that like when I look at
bioavailability,
um,
of micro nutrients,
it's like you can't find much better
than liver.
Like it's like the stuff is super
available.
Quite Alpha wolves immediately go to the
river when they kill something.
Yeah.
So like it and it,
so like it's like I need that.
Like,
I don't know.
I'm sure there's ranges of what people
can do in terms of absorbing something
like,
like a non heme iron versus a heme iron.
But like for me it's,
it's like if my iron levels below low,
the first thing I'm going to,
I'm doubling down on liver,
doubling down on liver and it's like far
as nutrients.
Just talking about,
just from a purely objective standpoint,
the consumption of nutrients,
organ meats are some of the best for
sure.
You're aware of Chris Kresser?
Yep.
Chris was a macrobiotic Vegan and you
know,
I mean he was like fully hardcore and
this was having all sorts of huge
issues.
His body just didn't react to it and he
fixed all that by eating organ meat.
And that's like his primary food source.
Yeah.
Um,
what's the Gal's name?
There's a lady who she can't remember
what she had.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm not going to think of it,
but if I do,
I'll remember.
But she did pretty much the same thing.
But some people are fine with the Vegan
diet too.
That's the other thing that's important
to point out.
It might not be the best for them in
terms of like bioavailability,
bioavailability of nutrients,
but it's certainly better than standard
western diet.
Sure.
American diet,
but for some people they can get by with
it and not have any issues.
Well,
some people get away with even more.
I mean Courtney to Walter Candy,
right?
Like it's candy and drinks beer,
Eatsa Nachos.
We took it to a Bagel place.
She fucking chow down hills and cream
cheese.
She's a fucking animal man.
I read an article about her not too long
ago and she said that she's got like
candy jar sitting around the house and
she's like,
before I go for a run,
I'll go anywhere from just like,
you know,
nibbling on it to a small stomach ache.
So we're not operating from the same
field I guess.
And that she's a real freak man,
you know,
there's people that know her that just,
they're stunned by her because what's
interesting about her is she's not a
fast runner in per say,
like,
like the way she would run a marathon.
She'd run a marathon and like three
hours.
So did she,
did she talk about how she got into
running when she was out here?
I believe she did.
Do you remember her specifically,
Jamie?
Sort of like you,
she ran in high school I think a little
bit,
but was she was teaching as well.
Okay.
Yeah.
While she was teaching,
she was running and doing these things
and then eventually she was able to get
enough sponsors so that she could run
full time,
which is what she does now.
But with with her,
I think,
and this is one of the reasons why I'm
fascinated by you folks with her,
it's her mind.
Her mind is just unbelievably powerful.
When she was experiencing cornea,
a deimos might hurt.
She couldn't fucking see man.
She was literally blind that she barely
could see her feet and she still won.
She fell,
cracked her head open,
blood's pouring down her head and she's
still one.
Was it,
was that at run rabbit run?
I don't think that was what it was.
Yeah,
I think that's what it was.
And there's an image of her crossing the
finish line.
Literally can't see shit.
She's got her hands in front of her.
She's covered in blood like she's up
fucking savage.
She's,
she's,
she's a,
if you take the,
then just think about ultra marathons is
like,
we kind of,
we're small enough sport where it's like
you can't really say like,
Oh,
I'm a hundred miler.
It's like,
okay,
you everybody,
wait.
No.
Well it's like,
yeah,
I know.
So like you have everything from a 50
kilometer that's got over 10,000 feet of
climbing and descending to a six day
event on a track and they're all the
same sport.
When you look at like people who can
kind of do really well at all of them or
in Courtney's case really well at all of
them,
you can't find a better female on the
female side of things.
Someone who can do it better than that
like she does.
She goes,
it goes on the track,
kills it.
She goes and 240 miles through the
mountains.
Kills it.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
She's something on really,
really unusual.
You know,
a buddy of mine,
my friend Brian,
it was texting me about her while she
was getting,
Brian is,
he doesn't even run,
I don't think are barely,
I mean it's not a,
but he was just so fascinated by this
one woman that was so far ahead of
everybody was like,
what the fuck is she doing?
Then she beat the second place guy by 10
hours in a 238 mile race,
22 miles.
She was ahead of him.
Yeah.
That's an interesting topic to where
like the,
where like men and women in an ultra
marathon and how that kind of like where
it's one of the rare races where women
can win.
And it's the,
the interesting thing to me about it is
women can and do win some races,
but when they're like,
like Courtney's very much the most,
I would say,
talented person to do one of the 200
milers.
Yet,
like there hasn't been a lot of what
like the,
the top of the sport hasn't really moved
into that.
I mean,
courtney certainly is top of the sport,
but she's,
I think she's the best.
I think she's the best woman all around.
Right?
If certainly in the United States thinks
she's the best at running those 200
milers,
uh,
is it dependent upon altitude gain and
loss and
bleed and it,
and just variables to the day?
I think like,
so like,
I mean,
there's,
there's some real,
like there's a guy named Kilian journey,
um,
and he spells his name,
j.
O.
R,
n,
e t and uh,
he won the,
um,
or he,
he's,
he's essentially the best mountain
runner by far.
Like there's maybe one of the guy who
could maybe compete with him at
something under a hundred miles,
but if it's like he's,
he's,
he would probably like beat everyone by
who knows how much in a 200 we've seen
one of these videos before.
Yeah.
He'll,
he'll run on these,
he'll run on these like ridge lines and
like,
it'll be the death on both sides and he
just
play these fucking guys,
man.
Oh,
I have cms.
This isn't even nearly as Shane.
Oh,
Mike.
Yeah,
that's,
that's crazy.
Look at him.
It looks like a freak to the gopro
strapped to his heaven.
That's gotta throw your balance off.
He's running with a Gopro.
Put that down intention.
That was my son.
I'd be like,
pay attention where you're running kid
Jesus.
Yeah,
he's interesting because I mean,
his parents were like mountaineers I
think,
and like,
so he was like basically playing in the
mountains at like age three and
basically grew up doing this stuff.
So yeah.
So he's the,
he's the type of guy who like,
he's,
he's probably the best in the sport
right now.
And it's
my guys jumping around.
He's an asshole.
He's,
he is running folks.
What is this a video?
Instagram.
I don't really know.
Okay.
[inaudible] spell his name.
Kay.
I is that two l's,
one l one l.
I.
A n.
And he's running in [inaudible].
How do you say that?
Chamonix chaminade.
Chamonix France.
And he's running one on what looks
like the fin of a shark.
If a shark was the size of a mountain,
this guy's a fucking animal,
man.
That is so scary.
Oh,
I get sweaty.
My hands are sweating just watching it.
And so he is the best on the mountains
for sure.
He doesn't do anything that's not
mountain.
It's like he did western states and one
in 2011 and he was complaining about it
being too flat.
Oh Jesus Christ.
What is the gain and loss of elevation
in Western net downhill?
So it's 2100 25,000 feet down.
17,000 feet up.
What?
So he's complaining about that.
Yeah.
It's too flat.
17,000 feet up and it gets much crazier.
And that you can do,
you can do like 50 miles or 100 k's that
have the same profile as that.
So you can get,
like,
if you're doing like what he's doing,
that probably does feel kind of flat for
him.
Like he likes that steep technical
stuff.
So,
but yeah,
so as far as the mountains go,
he's,
he's the guy to beat for sure.
And he'll do races on a regular basis
when he is running because he's actually
a professional skier too.
So like he's only running basically half
of the year and he's skiing.
The other half is Christ.
Yeah.
So He's,
he's a fun dude to follow for sure.
Um,
but yeah,
it's a w when you look at like some of
the races that are kind of the big
races,
like Western states,
100 is the most competitive hundred
miler in the United States and ultra
trail Mont Blanc,
which is actually by chaminade where you
saw that video,
um,
is probably at least a last year was the
most competitive in the world.
Um,
those are the reasons I like to look at
to kind of see like where the
divergences from the males and the
females.
Uh,
and if you look at like course records
and winning times,
like,
you know,
the men are finishing like two plus
hours ahead of the women are on a pretty
regular basis on that type of stuff.
And um,
at ultra trail mount blonde,
you know,
sometimes it's four or five hours,
uh,
and then it,
so then you can kind of lay,
it actually kind of is more in line with
what you see with other endurance
distances like marathons and stuff like
that.
Uh,
the crazy thing about it though is,
uh,
that doesn't mean that's going to happen
every time.
Like there's certainly years where women
do really well and finish like in the
top 10 amongst the in like look western
states or utm be,
um,
one year in 2006,
uh,
this gal and Nikki Kimball,
she finished third overall at Western
states was,
which is the highest finish finishing
finishing place for a woman other than
this other lady named Anne Treyson who
she hasn't really race anymore,
but she was,
she's kind of like the legend of the
sport from the women,
uh,
where she's,
she's uh,
um,
one western states like 14 times and had
like 20 world records at one point and
stuff like that.
And um,
but Nikki,
Nikki Kimball,
she finished third and part of it was,
cause that was like the hottest year in
the canyons on record.
And if women do,
one thing I'm pretty confident women do
better at these hundred miles in men is
they're not nearly as stupid.
Like the man will go out.
And like,
if it's competitive,
it takes one or two guys to kind of run
a little too fast and he's gonna bring
five,
six,
seven guys with them.
And then it's actually a fascinating
racing concept,
I think,
because then it's like if you're
watching it,
you're like,
okay,
one of these guys didn't have the race
of his life and hold on for dear life
and run a spectacular time.
Everyone else is going to blow up.
Apically when's it going to happen?
So you can thin out that men's field
really easily when that happens.
I think the women are a little smarter
than that.
They catch them off.
Right.
Wasn't,
wasn't there a guy that was like way out
ahead,
uh,
that,
that might've been the case.
Yeah,
he dropped off.
Yeah.
Keep it up.
He was probably running way too fast for
what he was capable of doing.
And then you see that all the time and
it's really easy to do at 100 plus miles
because really at the end of the day,
like if you feel comfortable at the
start,
you'll probably going to fast now.
How do you pace yourself and something
like that.
Like what do you,
are you using your watch?
Are you counting steps?
Like what are you doing?
Yeah.
Um,
I like to get to a point where I can use
perceived effort,
which is basically like listening to my
body and I can know like okay this is a
little too hard,
I need to dial it back.
Um,
I'll use heart rate a lot in training to
kind of get myself to the fitness I'm
looking for.
Your rich roll was talking about that he
was saying that he tries to stay under
one 40 or in the one 49 inch.
Yeah.
And the thing about heart rate that I,
where I kind of deviate from heart rate
is when you start getting into these
really long events that go past like two
or three hours,
heart rate starts losing its value in
terms of being able to trust it as like
a metric that's going to tell you to do
the right thing.
Like there's so many things that can
kind of disrupt that from like
dehydration to just cardiac drift,
all kinds of,
all kinds of things.
So I think like if an athlete really has
things dialed in that can use heart rate
and training and they can look at heart
rate if they want,
but they also need to connect that with
perceived effort so that if something
goes wrong with that or it starts,
you know,
issues start coming up with the heart
rate side of things,
they can still kind of like reflect back
in on themselves.
Like,
okay,
this is a state sustainable pace for me.
Or this is not a sustainable pace for
me.
Rich Roll,
we should point out is a Vegan.
Yeah.
And you know,
he's one of the few guys that is fully
functional.
It has no issues at all keeping that
diet up.
Yeah.
And I think he,
I mean,
he puts a lot of work into that,
I think.
Oh,
you have to.
Yeah.
I mean,
you really have to be just super
dedicated to making sure you're getting
the proper amount of nutrients and
making sure you get in microbiology and
all these different forms of b12 and
yeah.
Yeah.
And then whenever someone comes to me
and says like,
I'm a Vegan,
I'm a vegetarian or something like that,
it's like,
who should I look to?
And he's the,
he's the first guy I point to is like if
there's someone doing it right,
it's him.
So now he's definitely doing it right
now.
When it comes to something like Moab to
40,
how does someone like courtney below
that whole field,
the way like that?
Um,
I think some of it is just,
that's a really new event.
Like I think they're in their like third
or fourth year for two hundreds.
There's three of them in the United
States and they'll probably be four or
five in the next couple of years.
So it really hasn't,
it's in its infancy.
I mean,
think of it like,
uh,
like with UFC,
like back lake in the 90s,
like,
and then where does that today?
So like those two hundreds or kind of
like UFC was in the 90s.
And I mean,
if that becomes a thing,
if people start gravitating toward it,
then you're start,
you'll see some of these course records
just get blown out.
I mean we saw that with the hundred mile
distance and you've seen that with,
you know,
a lot of all the trail course records.
Um,
because like a lot of fast guys and gals
have moved into the sport and the last
five,
10 years.
So we've just been,
it's been like just deeper talent pool,
more likely to get a complete genetic
freak more likely.
And the other thing too is like,
um,
a lot,
like a lot of times what you have is you
get competitive enough in a sport then,
um,
people start playing with fire and
training and they're doing it because
they know they have to get to their
optimal best.
And sometimes they overtrain overtrained
get hurt and,
and then,
but then the people that make it through
that are there as fit as they can get.
So then you can see,
you can see some really good times.
Do you peak for a race?
Yeah,
definitely.
Same way a fighter would peak for a
fight.
Yup.
I'll usually pick two,
maybe three races a year and those are
the ones that I'm really going to try to
nail.
Those are the ones where like I'm gonna
like try to do everything I can to be
ready to hurt during that race.
And then I'll usually do,
maybe it's usually ranged,
like I'll usually do about six to eight
ultra marathons in a year.
And then the other ones are kind of like
those training races that I talked about
before or every once in a while I'll get
invited to a race that's like overseas
and it's like a free trip to go to China
or something like that.
We'll speak in birding
during a race.
I know that a lot of ultra runners are
utilizing cbd and even using edible
marijuana while they run and that they
found that this is a great performance
enhancing.
Yeah.
I don't know if you ever messed around
with CBD or,
Yeah.
Not,
not within workouts though,
like more as like a sleep aid or
anything but like,
or an inflammation thing.
So it's like more of a post war.
There was an esquire article,
Cole or Maxim,
one of them guy,
guy magazine type things,
and it was all about,
uh,
marijuana and ultra running and that
it's,
it's somehow or another,
uh,
become a big part of it that for a lot
of these guys,
yeah.
I think find a champion.
I,
you know,
it's interesting because like,
marijuana use,
I'm not sure about cbd,
but marijuana use is like,
is illegal in competition.
Yeah.
It's like all of them.
Uh,
yeah,
it's,
so there's like a Usada type standard.
It's the same,
it's the Usada Protocol.
So I think,
I think it's like,
it has to be below a certain level for
like,
that's great.
Then,
so they,
they're testing you for epo and all
those things.
I mean,
it's still pretty primitive and ultra
running,
um,
like there's testing at some of the big
races,
uh,
and that's even relatively new,
like in the last year or so.
So like Western states,
they'll test,
they'll test a,
the top 10 on each side and then a few
random people.
And then,
uh,
I think ut and B,
which is the other big hundred miler I
was talking about,
they tasks.
Like I was tested after when I broke the
$12 world record in 2013.
I got tested after that.
Um,
have there been any big superstars that
pissed hot?
Um,
there's been people who have,
uh,
they weren't like individuals that were
like kind of like a poster child of the
sport necessarily though.
Lamps,
Lance Armstrong,
nothing,
nothing like that.
So,
um,
and it's,
it's really interesting because like,
I mean there's certainly people skirting
the rules and ultra marathon running.
Um,
I have no doubt about it,
but I think they're doing,
uh,
probably like,
what is it?
Uh,
I dealt,
they're doing like blood transfusion,
things like Tour de France talk.
Cause I mean that's an expensive hard
thing to kind of put together.
You need a doctor essentially,
if I'm understanding it.
All right.
So they're probably just doing little
like minor things,
like maybe like peptides or something
like that would be my guess.
But I also do think it's not nearly like
people,
I think nowadays it would like with
Icarus and all that stuff,
like now people are on the opposite side
of what they were a few years ago where
they,
they suspect everyone's doing it versus
I know they're not doing it.
They haven't gotten caught yet,
which is where we were probably a few
years ago.
Um,
in ultra running.
I think,
I think the culture plays a huge role in
that.
I mean like when you had lance on and
they get,
he was pretty good about talking about
like how like,
you know,
like you come into the sport,
you go over to Europe to race and like
they asked you to get on a protocol.
If you say no,
they send you back.
Like it's like that's a cultural thing
then to like let it gets like you,
you have to do it to be in this sport
almost in with ultra running.
I just kind of the opposite.
I think.
Um,
I think the culture is stay away from
that stuff.
Like,
like we don't,
we don't want that
because it's a mind thing almost more
than anything,
which is why people like courtney who
aren't maybe the fastest marathon
runners but have this just bulletproof
mind that allows them to compete and
that you really,
there's no supplement for your mind for
willpower.
Yeah.
And there's things that can go wrong
just from the duration you're out there.
Yeah,
I can imagine.
I mean it seems to be so much of it
seems to be your ability to deal with
discomfort and pain and just press on.
Yeah.
It,
you know,
the way I describe ultra marathon
running is it's still a running sport.
See runner's high.
The athletes use marijuana to improve
their training.
What was that in?
Was it in the Guardian?
I taught both of those and yet,
but guardian stone,
marathon runners may seem like walking
contradictions,
but there are hints that the drug and
long distance running could go hand in
hand.
I'll tell you what,
man,
I've only done it a few times where I
got super baked and went running.
It feels awesome.
It feels great to feel so scared though.
Like,
ah,
what am I doing?
But I would imagine for some people it's
a,
you know,
euphoric,
50% of the runners are meaner,
avid cannabis user to say almost none of
them are open about it says avery.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Avery Collins is,
he's interesting because he's,
he's a spokesperson for marijuana use
and you know,
like,
I mean,
I don't,
you don't have to look far into like
marijuana and how it got to be where it
is in terms of its legality or
illegality to recognize there are some
tomfoolery going on there.
Like,
I mean,
you don't have to be like a historian to
find out like,
like why that's criminalized world,
whereas alcohol isn't,
and that sort of sorta thing.
And Avery's been like a pretty big
proponent about kind of,
uh,
de stigmatizing it.
Um,
and,
but you know,
he understands,
at least he understands that it's
illegal and competition.
And I think he's been tested at least
twice after races.
I mean,
he was six that western states last
year.
So he had gotten tested for that.
And Caffeine,
illegal and competition?
No.
Um,
I think at a certain level,
I think it is,
although they may have just removed it,
I'm trying to remember if I saw that
right.
But it used to be like you can have
caffeine but at a certain level it would
be illegal but it was like the
equivalent of like 16 cups of coffee or
something like that.
So you'd have to put down like four of
those Nitros
nitros right before your race if you
wanted any,
any chance of going over that.
And you probably go into cardiac arrest
before anyway and by the time you got to
the end of the race he would probably be
out of your system anyway.
Well,
it's interesting,
I actually,
this is
diverging a little bit,
but I,
I read a story a while ago that there
was some high school kid who was playing
football and he like slammed a red bull
or some one of those like high caffeine
energy drinks and then like was like on
the kick return team or something
returned to kick for touchdown,
was just jacked out of his mind,
slammed another one and then went back
on the field and had a heart
tack or something like,
I'm sure it could happen is you go too
hard.
It's not just caffeine.
Right.
A lot of those things have a bunch of
other worlds.
Once it,
I'm too,
you remember red lines?
Oh yeah.
I took one of those ones.
I drank the whole bottle and then I
looked at it,
it says like four servings.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
Well servings like 150 milligrams of
caffeine or something.
Nuts.
Yeah.
Well,
and then they put a bunch of other
stimulants in there that people don't
know about,
so yeah.
Tarin and all sorts of other shit in
there.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The kind of those pre workout
supplements were kind of wild.
Yeah.
Oh,
remember those a ripped fuel.
I took rip fuel once and went to a
Jujitsu class.
I had to stop.
I had to stop training.
I'm like,
I'm,
my heart is beating so fast.
I could die here.
Like this is,
this is not good.
And that was right before they pulled it
off the market.
Cut It in just in time.
I guess it was the other thing they
pulled off the market too,
that was killing people.
Was it called Jack Three D.
Oh,
okay.
I think I remember hearing them.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They,
that killed a few folks.
I think it killed a few folks in the
military.
So you know,
you're not talking about like some
fucking sickly old man's like,
I don't know,
have to get a truck.
It's like fucking soldiers.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'll use caffeine in races.
I think it's pretty clear that caffeine
is a performance enhancing and it just
happens to be one that's equally,
that's legal and some mild performance
enhancing and using coffee or taking
pills
a little.
I've done a variety of different things.
Um,
in I've done,
uh,
I did a race once where I was trying to
figure out like my fueling rate and like
kind of what was ideal,
and this was a while ago,
but I did 100 k race and I did nothing
but mountain dew and it was like,
wow.
I think I took in,
it ended up coming out to about 158
calories an hour of just mountain dew
with some luck.
I added some electro lights too.
I feel like if you,
if you're just sitting around doing
nothing,
mountain dews probably terrible for you
for sure.
If you're running hills and really
kicking ass like that,
the amount of fuel you're burning.
Yeah,
mountain dew might be a great move if
you don't go overboard.
I mean,
so does that every aid station at pretty
much every race?
Yeah.
So it's definitely something people have
identified as useful.
But like since then I've been a,
that product was talking about before
the x and fuel five.
They make one with a little caffeine in
it too.
So now I'll usually,
if I want to caffeine,
I'll just use that instead of the non
caffeinated one.
Um,
but then I'll do like,
you know,
I'll still sometimes do a little bit of
Soda,
especially at the end of the race.
Um,
just to kind of change things up a
little bit.
Cause that's the other thing too is like
if you do the same thing,
you know,
after a while it's like,
just give me something different.
Yeah.
Well I know floyd mayweather drinks soda
after he works out.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And,
and people were like,
what an idiot.
And I was like,
maybe not first of all,
maybe the best boxer of all time.
So definitely not an idiot.
He's doing something right.
He's doing something right and if he's
that good on top of,
you know,
having a terrible diet,
I think part of his like terrible diet
as a joke.
Like he'll eat cheeseburgers and shit
and show you and say,
look motherfucker,
I'm kicking everybody's ass eating
cheeseburgers.
But not really.
He really does help them when the chefs
making some gourmet meal,
I mean,
he has a personal chef.
There was a whole article about it
recently,
but I think that the fueling up with
like really heavy sugary drinks after a
very hard workout,
it's not a bad idea to replenish the
glycogen in your muscles.
Yeah,
I think that depends.
I think like,
I think the science is pretty clear if
you're on a high carbohydrate or a least
a higher carbohydrate diet that you
know,
carbohydrate and protein within like,
you know,
30,
45 minutes of the post workout is going
to be in your best interest of people
like chocolate milk for that.
Right?
Yeah.
That's gotten,
that's gotten kind of like labeled as
that perfect ratio of a protein with
shittier sugar.
Yep.
Where,
where it's not clear or at least it's,
it's getting clearer is like where the
variants there is for someone like
myself who following a high fat approach
and we have added a little bit of a
glimpse into it from some studies.
Uh,
and I,
the interesting thing is what they did
this one study called a faster study,
um,
and it looked at,
uh,
like it was 10 guys who are on a high
fat diet and 10 guys from on a high
carbohydrate diet and the guys on the,
they tried to pair them up as twin,
so like similar like performance
achievements,
a similar like body metrics and then
kind of compare the two in the high fat
cohort.
Actually when they finished the,
one of the workouts was a three hour
treadmill session and then they were,
they taken like blood tests and stuff
and they had like the oxygen mask and
things like throughout the course of it.
And they tested things before or after.
Um,
and one thing that they saw was like,
uh,
the,
the high fat folks actually had this
kind of big like surge of glucose in the
bloodstream post workout.
So the thought is like,
you might not want to double down on
that if you're in a fat adapted state
because like,
I mean,
some of the levels,
this is,
it goes back to,
it would have been like,
like this is what something I'd like to
ask a doctor a tia about.
Um,
is that like you get these big kind of
post workout,
like blood glucose spikes sometimes to
the level of like what would look like a
type two diabetic.
Um,
but it's not,
it's not,
it's,
it's in a different context than what
you would see in someone who's just like
following a normal diet where that would
be kind of a red flag.
And,
um,
so like to,
to hit the body with another source of
glucose essentially might not be
affecting you the same way.
So yeah,
it's,
it's interesting stuff.
So like,
it's actually like,
um,
what I've done sometimes too is after a
big hard workout,
if I'm not hungry,
I don't always eat right away.
I wait for my stomach to come around and
like my body to say,
you're hungry.
Just to let all that stuff kind of go
through.
And then,
then I'll have a,
depending on,
depending on what I'm doing next,
like all,
if I'm,
if I'm taking an easy day or a couple of
easy days,
I'll go like really low carb.
But if I'm going back out that afternoon
for another workout or the next morning
for like a speed session or something
out,
that's when maybe I would try to drop in
a little bit of carbohydrate to kind of
speed up the glycogen,
uh,
side of things.
So I'm ready for that next one.
Well,
Zach,
you're a bad mother fucker.
I wish you all the best and I really
appreciate you coming down here and
talking to us and it's a fascinating
what you do,
man.
Thanks for having me on.
Thank you.
Thank you very much,
man.
Thank you.